so obviously the big story last week is
that russia led by vladimir putin has
invaded ukraine okay ukraine is an
independent nation they have largely
allied with the west over the last
decade or so and putin for weeks
actually for about the last two months
this was a sort of slow-motion war right
we kept hearing there's going to be a
war one of these days in in ukraine
russia is going to send troops in and
biden kept hinting it too it was almost
as if biden was acting as putin's press
agent well he may go in and we're
thinking about what he's going to do and
he may and if he has to we'll do what he
does all the usual nonsense so i'm going
to try my best
i really mean this i always try this but
i really mean it for this because it's
just such a cluster
f
of misinformation out there uh i'm gonna
do my best to lay out sort of a uh let's
say an unemotional case as to what
really is going on here and then i can
obviously share my opinions on that so
we looked for a bunch of stuff and
phoenix found this piece from ben
shapiro and obviously ben shapiro he
knows his stuff i think we read it and i
thought it was like a pretty solid
version of just the facts of what's
going on right now so this is from the
daily wire
from ben shapiro so russia has invaded
ukraine the invasion has been a long
time in the making so what drove putin
the answer comes from putin's own mouth
just days ago he gave a militant speech
in which he said ukraine is not just a
neighboring country for us it is an
inalienable part of our own history
culture and spiritual space since time
immemorial the people living in the
southwest of what has historically been
russian land have called themselves
russians the real reason putin is moving
now is threefold first russia has a
major advantage right now natural gas
and oil europe has spent the last decade
destroying its own energy capacity at
the behest of greta thunberg and company
second the west has demonstrated utter
incapacity to challenge putin's prior
predations putin has no reason to think
that any consequences will be either
long lasting or significant and on a
broader level putin has watched as the
west surrenders to aggressive
dictatorial powers repeatedly from hong
kong in 2020 to afghanistan in 2021
third putin envisions a reimagined world
order he clearly lusts for a return to
russian glory and he sees that china has
oriented itself under xi jinping toward
a similar purpose so let me back out for
just one second so okay so that that's a
basic explanation of what's going on
here using putin's own words he just
believes fundamentally that ukraine
belongs to greater russia okay right
like that's just the sort of basic idea
here now you can believe
uh that that is true or not the
ukrainian people obviously
do not believe that and i believe that
they have a right to defend their own
land as i would argue any people on
earth have a right to do and how you go
about doing that that is where the the
devil lies in the details okay so this
was a slow motion attack for about two
weeks where they kept saying we're going
to do it when are we doing it there's
going to be a troop build up there was
all this weird stuff like is it going to
happen it has to happen and then things
sort of get their own entropy and
clearly it was on the way we all knew it
was going to happen and it was just a
matter of when it was going to happen so
first we have a video compilation of uh
some of the attacks going on in ukraine
by the russian army
yes
[Music]
[ __ ] you so you might not
[Music]
so
okay so the reason i wanted to show you
guys that and i'm sure you're seeing the
clips on twitter or wherever else you go
for this kind of stuff but the reason i
want to show you that little compilation
there was because this is real this is
real stuff you know if you watch
mainstream media it's so much about the
the players involved right this is putin
wants to go in and do this and it seems
almost inhuman that there's no human
level of what's going on there those are
people's houses those are people's
apartments these uh ukraine is a free
sovereign nation that's a member of the
united nations
and russia just decided to go in
for whatever their
reasons are that they believe in this
greater russia russia idea that's what
putin believes in and they just decided
we're going to kill people we're going
to
attack infrastructure we're going to
cause people to flee
right now in ukraine if you're a male
between i believe it's 18 and 61
they're basically drafting you into the
army right now they're handing out
weapons which sort of makes you think
that perhaps uh citizens should have
weapons it's a good thing we've got that
second amendment here in the united
states um and i also wanted to mention
that on a personal note of this you know
we have a local's office uh in ukraine i
don't want to say what city it's in but
the city is under attack right now uh
and i want to give a shout out to six of
our guys that are there mikola maxim
vitale vlad and evgeny um all work
in in one of our offices they're uh
they're safe we're we're in contact the
staff the ceo of locals is in contact
with them and we're trying to figure out
what we can do to help them um and
it's real like this is real stuff these
are people that just want to
live that did not anticipate that you
know say six months ago oh we'd be
fleeing our homes or we'd be separated
from our families or anything else so
it's uh there's a human part of this
that i just think we can't forget
because we can all get lost in in the
sort of social media part of it of putin
versus biden and all of that stuff
anyway what's what's particularly
interesting uh about all of this is that
the ukrainian president his name is
vladimir zelinski and in a bizarre twist
as i'm sure some of you have heard
already he is a comedian he is a
stand-up comedian he is a jewish
stand-up comedian so this in essence is
like if jerry seinfeld became the
president of the united states that's
sort of what happened here in ukraine
makes you you know it's like all right
pretty good you know why not have a
comedian as president or prime minister
seems good enough well this guy has
proven himself to be what a true
leader is so we just talked about justin
trudeau a moment ago a guy who wants
power to control people well many
leaders would have fled the country by
now because he knows zelensky that there
is a mark on him right like putin would
gladly take him out if given the
opportunity and perhaps he's just
waiting for the right moment well
zielinski is is not leaving he could
leave he is not leaving he is staying
and fighting here's his first message to
the people of ukraine and to the world
i want you to really for just one second
think about the bravery this guy there
is no doubt with russian intelligence
they know exactly where zelensky is
there is no doubt simply no doubt that
through a drone strike or whatever other
means or a jet or whatever they got to
do a guy on the ground that they could
take him out and there he is standing
there saying we will defend our land we
will defend our country this is not what
most leaders would do it really is not
what most leaders would do in a
situation like this a situation that
seems so insurmountable right the
ukrainian army is nothing compared to
the russian army but it's not just
zielinski
that is proudly defending his nation
he's got a whole bunch of other
officials that have not fled kiev and
are standing and fighting and making
sure the world knows
the leader
of officer
we are not going to flee we are going to
defend our independence i mean
that's what it's all about and and to
see leaders doing the right thing it's
it's rare these days